JOHANNDU TOIT: So welcome
to Google Developer's Africa
broadcast.
So just a quick intro.
We're all GDEs here.
In the GDE program, we are
appointed in different regions,
acting as resources
and the people
to go guide local students
and companies, just
help with Google, and
just direct your chats,
our needs back to
Google HQ, and see
if they can help us in Africa.
So let me just introduce
the premise of the show.
We're going for monthly,
downloadable MP3,
which we hope you can get.
If you get it to watch later,
let's see how that goes.
And we are looking for people
to invite to the live Hangouts.
So later in the show, we're
going to post our links.
Please go to the
form, fill it in.
We'd love to have you.
And we're really trying to
base this off a theme base.
So every episode,
we're going to try
to focus on one thing,
which in this episode,
you might see the title.
I'm going to hand
off to Hiren now,
who's going to explain
and introduce the panel.
HIREN PATEL: Hi, guys.
So an introduction of who's on
the panel today, I am Hiren.
I'm a Cloud based
GDE in Cape Town.
Johanndu, who you've
met, is a Cloud
based GDE in Cape Town,
as well, and the founder
of a few startups
here in Cape Town.
We have Alex, Android GDE, and
the author of the Cape Town
MyCiTi Android app, and Dale,
Cloud GDE, and CTO of Nomanini
here in Cape Town.
So you've seen the theme
for this episode is staying
connected in Africa, and it's
all about giving your users
a good experience,
taking into consideration
the internet connectivity
challenges of Africa.
So as we all know,
mobile is king in Africa,
but in a lot of areas,
the mobile networks
and the mobile connectivity can
be very patchy, high latency,
low frequent, and
even nonexistent.
Now, most mobile apps today make
use of a Cloud-based back end,
which is generally very great,
but a problem comes into play
when these apps don't
take into consideration
that they don't always have
access to this Cloud back end.
What happens as a result
is that they aren't
able to provide the basic
functionality to the users,
and this gives the users a
bad experience on the app.
So all apps in Africa
need to be able to provide
the base functionality even when
they can't access their Cloud
back end.
And that's the
discussion, that's
the topic of discussion today.
We're going to go into
some depth on the problems,
as well as some
solutions around this.
So the schedule
going forward, we
will have Alex and Dale present
on the subject for 10 minutes.
We will then have a Q&A
session for five minutes.
We will have a closing and wrap
up for five minutes thereafter.
If you have any questions,
please post the questions
to the YouTube video
section, and we
will take those questions in the
Q&A. Just before I hand over,
we have our latest
Cloud GDE, Kenneth,
joining us from Nairobi
as well, on the panel.
JOHANNDU TOIT: Hi, Ken.
HIREN PATEL: So I'll hand
over to Alex and Dale
to kick it off.
DALE HUMBY: I'm Dale.
Mobile networks in Africa
can often be unreliable,
and they drop calls and
connections at the worst time.
Data's also expensive, with
some networks charging as much
as $1.00 per megabyte for data.
So at first, I'm going
to talk on the basis
of how mobile networks work, and
why things sometimes go wrong.
And then I'm going to
talk about some things
to keep in mind while
you're designing an app.
And then hand over to Alex,
who's going to talk about some
of the potential solutions
for overcoming these problems.
We'll try to switch over
to some slides quickly.
Let's get them open here.
So while your phone
is switched on,
it is always connected to at
least one mobile base station,
and if it isn't, it tries
hard to get connected.
And say you wanted to visit
a web page on your phone,
your phone sends that request
to the nearest mobile base
station, which routes your
data to a switching center,
and then, from there, it's
routed onto the internet.
As you travel around, your
phone roams from base station
to base station.
Up to seven towers are connected
to your phone at any time.
This allows your phone to hand
over between towers seamlessly,
so data and voice calls
don't get dropped.
Your phone sends data to
any tower it's connected to,
and the tower routes that
data to a switching center,
and then on to the internet,
and replies are sent back
from a server that
you're connecting to,
to all the towers that
your phone is connected to,
and then back on to your phone.
This is sort of like a monkey
swinging from branch to branch.
The monkey won't let
go from one branch
before it's holding
onto the next one.
But sometimes, the branch
that you want to go to
has too many other monkeys
on it and there's nowhere
for you to go.
So say you're
traveling, and you're
connected to a
first base station,
and there's loads of devices
on the second base station.
You don't know that,
but you continue
traveling towards the second
one, the base station that's
now overloaded.
Your phone is still
connected to the first tower,
and your data connection
and your voice call is fine,
but you can't get to
second base station,
because too many
other connections are
open on that one.
Eventually, you travel too far
from the first base station.
The signal is weak and
the connection breaks.
But you're still not connected
to the closer, busy base
station.
And at that point, the call
fails because you're not
connected to anything.
And if you're
trying to use data,
well, you can't get a
data connection either.
So let's look at what's
happening under the hood.
GSM networks, which is
primarily what we use in Africa,
use what's called TDMA, or
Time Division Multiple Access,
to allow many devices to connect
to the same base station.
Each base station has 124
channels, roughly at about 900
megahertz or 1800 megahertz.
And each channel has
eight time slots.
Each phone will
transmit during a time
slot for a few milliseconds,
and then the next phone
will transmit for the next
few milliseconds, and so on.
This happens so quickly
that you don't notice it.
It's very similar in the
way that operating systems
can run many programs, even
with only one or two CPUs.
On a base station, some time
slots will be used for voice,
and the other free time
slots can be used for data.
As more people use
the base stations,
the networks prioritize
voice over data,
because they make more
money on voice calls.
So they reduce the number of
data time slots available.
Eventually, if a base station
is completely overloaded,
all the time slots
are used for voice
and nothing is left for data,
and you can't get any data
through to the servers.
So that's a little background
of how mobile networks work,
and why sometimes your
calls are dropped,
and you can't get a data
connection, even when it looks
like you've got good signal.
So given that data
connections can be flaky,
what can we do about it?
Well, the first solution is to
transmit as little as possible.
Data costs are expensive, some
people paying as much as $1.00
per megabyte.
And if you're using HTTP,
you can reduce the data
by using a compact data format,
like JSON instead of XML
and you can use GZIP for
something like a 50% savings.
Sorry, can we just
switch back to that?
There we go.
I'm back.
As I was saying, if you're
using something like HTTP,
you can use JSON as a
compact data format over XML.
And then you can GZIP it.
And we found that
GZIPing data can
add as much as a 50% savings.
But something that I
only realized recently
is compression is only on the
server side and for downloads.
If you want to compress
uploads, you probably
have to roll something
to back your app.
You can use GZIP or another
protocol like Deflate.
But I found it's worth it.
In some data that
I've been doing,
I've had as much as a 50%
savings, especially when
you batch those uploads.
Some actually might not
need to use data compression
because you may be uploading
images or movie clips.
And formats like
JPEG and MPEG, which
are used for images and
movies are already compressed,
and compressing them again with
GZIP is not going to help much.
Just remember to resize
your photos on the app,
on the client's side,
before you upload them.
You can also batch
requests and responses.
If you're doing
many small requests,
there's a lot of
overhead in HTTP headers,
and a cookie, which is
used for authentication,
can be as much as 1 to 2
kilobytes, versus maybe
100 or 200 bytes that
you're trying to send up,
and that's a 10 times overhead,
instead of-- yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
HTTP/2, which is based
on Google's SPDY protocol
overcomes these issues.
It's already supported on
Android using the OkHttp stack.
All the normal browsers
are supported already.
That only sends
those headers once,
and there's many
other optimizations
that you can do which it has
got built in for mobile usage.
And only send when you need to.
If a server needs to send
a message to a client,
use [INAUDIBLE] messaging.
Don't pull the
server the whole time
if you need to get a connection.
WebSockets is an
attractive connection
between the server and client.
And the server can
send data to the client
without having to pull.
SSL, which is
encryption, is important,
and prevents things like third
parties from sniffing data
and man-in-the-middle attacks,
especially over public Wi-Fi
like internet cafes,
coffee shops, airports.
But the problem is it adds
latency to your application.
It takes 12 packs to
negotiate a SSL connection.
And that's three round trips
over the mobile network,
compared to just three
packets, or one round
trip from an unencrypted
TCP connection.
But if you're using
something like HTTP/2,
it keeps the connection open
for as long as possible,
and is reused.
Reducing data also
has the benefit
of reducing battery usage.
Continuously transmitting
data, especially in poor signal
areas, uses a lot of
power, because when
the phone is struggling
to get a signal,
it boosts the transmitter
power to get your data through.
And on that note,
if you're using GPS,
think about how often you really
need to update the position.
GPS uses a lot more
battery than even GSM coms.
Fused Location
Provider on Android
estimates a position
based on the cell network
and surrounding
Wi-Fi base stations.
And so your app doesn't
need to use GPS as often.
Data and battery hungry apps
get deleted by users, or worse,
they get a one star rating.
I'm now going to
hand over to Alex,
who's going to talk about
building Android apps that
handle these difficult
network conditions.
ALEX KOLLER: Thanks Dale.
My name is Alex and I'm
an Android developer.
And from what Dale
has presented,
it's pretty clear that we have
some challenges to overcome
with these networking problems.
The good news is that the
Android framework actually
handles a lot of
these things for us.
At least in the recent
versions, KitKat and Lollipop.
But using the open
OkHttp library,
you can get the
same results using
all the versions of Android.
And this generally takes care
of things like request retries,
simple caching, selecting
the right protocols,
such as HTTP/2, and other
low level things like that.
What we're going to do is
discuss some techniques
you can use while building
your apps to help you create
the best possible user
experience even when
the network isn't
being your best friend.
First thing is storing
everything on the client.
Persist everything in an
appropriate data store,
such as SQLite.
This means you'll
always, always have
data available to show
immediately in your UI
if you have a slow
or no connection.
Even if the data is a bit
old, it's usually better
to show that than nothing.
By combining a sync
adapter, content provider,
and cursor loaders, which are
all available in the Android
framework, you can update
your data in the background,
and always be sure
that the latest data is
showing in the UI immediately.
Speaking of the UI,
never block the UI when
you're doing network requests.
As a user, there's nothing
worse than being stopped
in your tracks while you
wait for some networking task
to complete.
Whether that's fetching new
data or posting a new message,
there are very few times it
makes sense to block the UI
and prevent the user from
actually using your app.
This is especially true on slow
and unreliable connections.
If you need to indicate that
there's an ongoing process,
use a small inline progress
indicator inside the views.
This shows the user
that something's
happening, but doesn't
stop them from using
the rest of your app.
But even better, is if you saved
the changed data on the device
and update the UI immediately.
And you can assume
that their request
will finish successfully.
However, if it doesn't,
you must alert the user
that it's changed and roll back
that change that you've saved.
This can be a little
bit tricky, but I
think it's well worth
it, in my opinion.
There's one special case where
you do need to block the UI.
And that's when you
have first loads,
or after user logs in, when
there is no data to show,
and you have to fetch
it from a server.
It's important to fetch that
data as quickly as possible.
However, most apps have a
summary dashboard type screen
where we show a
bit of everything,
a summary of the entire app.
And if you have a
nicely designed,
restful API, that
means you'll have
to fetch information from a
number of different endpoints.
What I usually do
is I combine those
into a single API endpoint.
That allows me to fetch
all of the information
for the first screen in
one single request, which
is far more efficient than
doing multiple requests
on the network.
And this results in a shorter
load time for your apps.
One other thing to keep in
mind is always push data
to the devices whenever
possible, instead of pulling.
As Dale mentioned, this
is a preferred technique
in terms of data
transfer because updates
get to your users
faster, but it also
has less of an impact on
battery and data costs.
You can use Google Cloud
Messaging for this on Android.
That covers some
basic techniques
we can use for handling
unreliable and expensive
networks, but how can
we get the back end up
and running quickly?
I've used App Engine
a few times recently,
and it's a great option for
a low maintenance back end.
You can use Java to
get going quickly,
and there's a free daily
[INAUDIBLE] for most apps.
However, it doesn't
offer specific support
for any of the things we've
mentioned today out of the box.
That's where things like
Firebase come into play.
Firebase is described as a
complete back end solution.
There's no other coding
required, or even possible,
on the back end.
It basically provides
an API for your data,
and handles other things,
such as authentication
and common networking tasks.
One of the benefits is
it's cross-platform,
so it works on web,
iOS and Android.
But the real gem
of this software
is the client-side SDKs.
They support offline mode
and data synchronizations.
That means that you can
persist data on the device
while there's no
network connection
and then in the background
it'll synchronize
that with the server.
This is one of the trickiest
problems to deal with.
So it's fantastic having
that done well for you.
There's also a free pricing
option to get started.
I haven't used it
extensively, but I
do think it's great
for prototype,
especially for apps that
require real time syncing,
such as mobile
[AUDIO OUT] applications.
So to wrap up, remember
to always store your data
on the device, so you can
display it immediately.
Never block the UI when
doing network requests.
Load all of your
data that you need
upfront in a single request.
And push data to
the device instead
of pulling for it to save
battery and data costs.
With all the links to the things
we've mentioned in this talk,
feel free to [AUDIO OUT] so
that we can share that with you.
HIREN PATEL: Cool, thanks guys.
So we're now going to
take some questions.
Just a reminder, if you're
watching this live on YouTube,
please post your questions.
I'll read your comments.
We're watching those as well.
So for the first
question, what apps
would be a good example of
how to handle a connection
failure well?
And how do they do it?
ALEX KOLLER: One app I
think does this quite well,
based on the web, is
the Gmail Inbox app.
When you're typing an email,
you don't get any indication
that it's saved or not saved.
You assume it's saved.
But if you lose a connection,
there's a subtle reminder
that this draft is not saved.
But it lets you continue
with what you're doing,
and when the network comes back
up, everything syncs again.
DALE HUMBY: [INAUDIBLE].
One of my favorite
apps is 8tracks,
and it's a media, well, it's
like an online radio station,
except what they do in
the background is they
stream an MP3 to your phone.
So it's not trying to do live
streaming off of content,
like in a [INAUDIBLE].
It just sends an MP3.
And as soon as the
first MP3 has been
downloaded in the playlist,
it downloads the next one.
So there's always
something there.
So when you're in spotty
connections, like in a lift
or in underground parking,
it still works pretty well.
HIREN PATEL: OK.
Still thinking framework
and it stops working.
How would I go about this?
What should I do as a developer?
ALEX KOLLER: Well, when I was
playing around with Firebase,
there are things in the SDK to
allow you to react to a failed
connection or a failed sync.
And it's really up
to the application.
It depends on the context
of the application, how
you bubble that up to the
user, whether you do at all.
Sometimes you can
just throw away data.
Sometimes you don't
want to throw away
people's love letters.
So it depends on the app,
but the frameworks all
allow a way of knowing
what went wrong,
and how often it went wrong.
HIREN PATEL: Cool.
So for the next one,
can sync frameworks
work with hybrid apps, given the
rise of hybrid apps these days?
ALEX KOLLER: Well, if
a hybrid app is just
a web app running in a
web view, theoretically,
with something like Firebase,
you could use the web SDK
and get similar
results to native.
But I doubt the reality
is quite that simple.
Every time I've been
involved in a hybrid app,
it has never been simple.
DALE HUMBY: You're not a great
fan of hybrid apps, are you?
ALEX KOLLER: How can you tell?
[LAUGHTER]
DALE HUMBY: How about using
the HTML5 or cloud storage?
ALEX KOLLER: Yeah, that's
actually a good example.
I read something just
the other night about
how, I think it was
Google, years ago,
they started downloading massive
CSS and JavaScript files,
chopping them up into
strings, and then
storing those strings
in local storage.
DALE HUMBY: Right.
ALEX KOLLER: So if it didn't
have the CSS and JavaScript
required for the page, it
would just go and request
the pieces it needs.
So now there are
imaginative ways
you can use HTML technologies.
HIREN PATEL: Cool.
So what is the difference
between [AUDIO OUT]
Any comments around that?
DALE HUMBY: Sure.
Most of my knowledge is on 2G
networks, so the GPRS and EDGE,
and that's from the early
1000s, and uses TDMA.
And it's pretty reliable and
available almost everywhere.
A lot of the networks are sort
of building out 3G and then
HSDPA.
Mobile users are a whole
completely different protocol
for transporting
and receiving data.
It's, as far as I
know, it's CDMA,
so it's just a different stack,
entirely different frequencies.
And a lot of the new
networks are now using LTE.
And the newest
ones in Africa have
found that they skipped
right over 3G entirely,
and they're just
installing LTE now.
So they might have--
GPRS might have.
EDGE, certainly they'll have
3G and then now installing LTE.
And the guys that
don't install LTE now
might skip over to
whatever's next.
ALEX KOLLER: Well, that's
great news, actually,
because I've read and
experienced that 2G
is a painful experience.
But 3G was a great
advancement on that,
but there were also problems,
especially initializing
the radio on mobile devices.
It can get up to a 2 1/2
second delay from when you make
the request to when it
actually leaves your device.
And LTE, and HSDPA made
massive improvements
on this, where those times are
down to under 100 milliseconds.
So the future is looking fast.
HIREN PATEL: Nice.
So do we have any other
questions in the panel?
It doesn't look like it.
You could always,
after the event,
we are an open community,
so just post your questions.
Yes, so if haven't
joined the community.
So if you have
questions about anything
we've spoken about,
please post the date
and we'll be happy to
answer it at a later point.
I'll hand it back
over to Johanndu.
JOHANNDU TOIT: All right, so
first, thank you Dale and Alex.
Awesome talk.
This is the section
where we would
like to have you, the
community, come and show us
what you're doing, any
problems you're experiencing,
and just spotlight what the
rest of Africa is doing.
So we decided to keep it blank,
and rather than do a call out,
after the show, we're going
to put out a post with a link,
and just follow the link,
and fill in the form,
and we'll be in contact.
Especially with the
[INAUDIBLE] shows,
we're looking for
something that fits,
and just something
that's generally cool
and shows how innovative
we are in Africa.
And so next up, it's Alex
and Hiren attended ScaleConf.
I don't know if
you guys know it.
It's a conference
down in Cape Town.
They're going to tell you more.
ALEX KOLLER: Yeah.
Hiren and I recently attended
ScaleConf in Cape Town.
It's probably the
conference with the best
venue in the world.
It's right here in
Kirstenbosch Botanical Gardens.
And we gave a talk on
scaling Android apps
with Google Cloud
Messaging and App Engine.
The talk itself is fascinating.
The video will be
available soon.
But I wanted to talk
more about ScaleConf
and what makes it great.
And I think because it's
really well organized,
has an interesting
content in the tech
talks, and also
the format of it,
a single track format with
breaks between every talk.
It worked really well.
Everyone was always attentive
and enjoying the talks.
So we'd love to see
more conferences
like this in Africa.
So please let us know about
any conferences or events
that you've really enjoyed so
we can share a bit about them.
HIREN PATEL: On the
topic of events,
we have a events category
in the G+ community.
We encourage everyone to go
in the events over there,
events run by your local GDG.
If you are a GDG organizer,
please reshare your events
under the Events section
of the community for us
to see as well.
On that note, I'd like to
make mention of two upcoming
important events.
The first one is the
Google I/O. So this
is Google's annual major
developer conference.
They live stream this as well.
And folks around the
world, including GDGs,
will get together for
extended viewing parties
and watch the live
stream together.
So do look out for an
extended party near you,
or even start one if
you don't have one.
And share it with us in the
community events [INAUDIBLE]
as well.
The other one is
the UX Masterclass.
This is the Google-run
workshop-like event.
It happened for the
first time last year.
And it's all around user
experience and user interfaces.
If this interests
you, this is happening
at the beginning of May in
Nairobi, Cape Town, and Lagos.
So look out for that as well.
They are posted to the events
section of the community
as well.
So back to Johanndu about
the future of the show.
JOHANNDU TOIT: So let
me just take us out.
First off, thank you for coming
to watch the first episode.
We're still trying
to find this show,
but this was a structure show,
so please give us feedback.
We're going to be
posting in a link.
So just tell us what you
liked, what you didn't like,
and [INAUDIBLE] towards.
.
That's implied.
Also, very important,
the guest speakers,
we'd love to feature you.
So thank you for attending
and hope to see you next time.